Americans will vote in the midterm
elections in fewer than three weeks the
latest CBS News poll infer dicks if the
elections were held today Democrats
would win 226 seats in the House of
Representatives eight more than the 218
needed to take control House Speaker
Paul Ryan is not running for re-election
but he is campaigning for fellow
Republicans like New York congresswoman
Elise Stefanik we talked about issues
that matter to voters and whether
they're the tax cut they are running on
has ballooned the deficit plus the
spread of tribalism in politics our
Republicans going to keep the house I
think we are I feel pretty good about it
why I think our voter enthusiasm is
where it needs to be and more
importantly we have a great record to
run on the agenda that we ran on in 2016
is the agenda that we executed in 2017
and 2018 and it's working the economy is
booming the military is being rebuilt
the Veterans Administration has been
overhauled we have deregulated
businesses so they can hire again
congressman when we talked last when
you're at the table for CBS this morning
you said it was a tough political
climate why well I think there's a lot
of volatility John in terms of the media
pace it is faster than any time I've
experienced but I'm very proud to be
running on my record of results mr.
speaker you has helped pass a tax cut
there's a Gallup poll that says only 39%
of the country approves of that tax cut
a 46% does not and 51% say the tax cuts
have not helped financially so that
doesn't seem like a very good record
people don't seem to be buying it I
think the the narrative and the
political rhetoric is obviously mixed on
this but when you break it down into its
component parts it's overwhelmingly
popular people are excited at the fact
they're gonna have a doubled child tax
credit this year people like the fact
that their standard deductions have been
doubled but when you say break it down
into its component parts that's exactly
what they said about the affordable care
act which had this kind of dismal
approval so that it's just people aren't
aren't fine you say wages are up by now
money in your own pocket versus paying
higher health insurance premiums I think
the answer is pretty clear on this
people like the fact that they're
getting bonuses that 90% of American
workers have bigger paychecks this year
fiscal policy speaking about mr.
speaker we have new deficit numbers 779
billion dollars in this last year added
to the deficit 523 billion in interest
payments that's the highest on record
that deficit numbers the biggest since
2012 when we were in a recession but if
this were a situation where you were
trying to regain control of the house
you would be talking about the deficit
from beginning to end of your speeches
but now you're on the hook for it
revenues are up this year believe it or
not we cut taxes at the beginning of the
year and we have higher revenues this
year why do we have higher revenues
because we have faster economic growth
higher wages more taxes are coming into
the government you say you have higher
revenues by those CEOs we have higher
rent but if you account for inflation
if you account for some of those
revenues come from previous tax policy
before this bill and then if you take
into account that the revenue that would
increase from population you're actually
revenues are lower than they made you
say this way as a result we cut taxes
and we have higher revenues coming into
the government today still but you know
but you know that numbers a wobbly
number and that it's actually lower than
it would be had the policy remained if
the economy Hatta grow that's exactly
right but the economy did grow no not
even though you've had economic we had
4.2 percent growth in this last quarter
that higher economic growth brings in
more revenues i've actually produced
more than the promises I made how often
do you hear that you've seen to me
president Trump's rallies do those
rallies accentuate the things that unite
us
the bipartisan achievements or are they
do they do something very successful in
politics as wildly successful which is
so division in the countries do you see
that happening at his rallies sometimes
yeah sometimes meaning well not always
but sometimes I worry about tribal
identity politics becoming the new norm
of how politics is waged as
conservatives we always thought this was
sort of a left-wing Lenski thing
unfortunately the right practices
identity politics now as well you've
talked about inclusive politics which
tries to unified as president Trump
practice those kind of politics
sometimes he doesn't sometimes he
doesn't how but I mean come on honestly
no I look at an economic roof and then
tax reform on getting the military and
helping veterans those are things that
he has led us to that have really
brought people together I
think this election is going to be
focused on results versus resistance
what I know does not resonate with
voters is this resistance effort where
regardless of whether you agree with
some of the focus of this administration
you're unwilling to work with them so I
think both parties need to address the
tribalism that's happening I was a
spirited conversation no I'm wondering
when it was over did he go nice to see
you John Dickerson we've had these
conversations over a long time and you
know he answers the question then you
know and then you go back and forth
which is what's known as an interview
you know you said no no but really and
well he got a little flustered
well here's the thing he has devoted his
life to a very different style of
politics and he admits that that style
of politics is not in vogue another
style has been very successful Donald
Trump has remade the Republican Party in
his image but that's not the Paul Ryan
image so what's more effective to do
what's he gonna do Oh Paul Ryan well he
says he wants to talk about this idea of
tribalism in politics one of the things
we discussed was how do you do that from
the outside when it's when when in the
inside the instinct is always to try and
get things done he also wants to go back
and try and do some work on poverty you
know he spent a long time out of the
spotlight trying to work on the issue of
poverty I think he wants to work on that
he wants to spend some time with his
kids in the backyard doing nothing yeah
it was spirited but it was respectful
yeah that's what we go for this
interview